[Musica]
mi chiamasse siamo a sona in arte
sparagna e con bari show non so quanti
ci sono quanti abruzzesi abruzzesi si
sono qui possiamo fare per alzata di
mano vi siano ancora usato questa
modalità grazie sparagna e compari ci
vuol dire risparmi e fa bella figura nel
senso che non bisogna spendere
eccessivamente tanto per apparire e
questo è il motto del mio brand o della
mia pagina
ma tornando a sparando a cuba risce non
è solo una questione di apparire ma
anche di tornare ad apprezzare le cose
semplici della vita si può andare nei
paesi dei borghi ormai dimenticati e
visitare luoghi che ormai sono sono
stati abbandonati e quindi io ho deciso
di rimanere in abruzzo anche per questo
motivo perché un sacco di persone mi
dicevano sempre ma che ci fai ancora qui
a basso perché non vieni con a milano a
lavorare a cercare lavoro
io dicevo no io resto a vasto perché
voglio provare a rimanere qui e crearmi
qualcosa di mio
e per questo mi sono buttata creando una
maglietta simpatica che parla di un cibo
tipico abruzzese
non so se avete mai mangiato le pallotte
cace esatto
quindi è nato tutto per scherzo dalle
pallotte cace e ove ho iniziato a
frequentare grazie a loro ho iniziato a
frequentare tantissime sagre ed eventi
conoscendo un sacco di ragazzi che mi
hanno fatto apprezzare ancora di più la
mia regione e mi hanno dato tantissimi
stimoli a continuare il mio lavoro in
questi paesi
ho conosciuto anche tantissime signora
che mi hanno fatto delle domande assurde
un giorno nero finita a bomba possa
andare al lago e tomada andiamo in paese
a vedere come il vicolo le storie le
strade in quel momento stavano sondando
tantissime campane si affaccia una
signora ci guarda e ci dice ma chi sei
morto e noi o dio signor scusi non siamo
del posto
non lo sappiamo che è morto a e che ci
fate qui vi siete persi qui non ci viene
mai nessuno
questo paese ormai all'abbandono che ci
fate quel ragazzo ha detto noi stiamo
provando a visitare posti per farli
conoscere a ragazzi che come noi sono
nutrendo le nostre stesse passioni
in quel momento capii anche che il
motivo per cui stavo rimanenti d'abruzzo
perché la mia missione oltre a far
conoscere la regione
a far apprezzare le piccole cose della
vita era far conoscere un altro
significato del fumo non conoscete
questo termine anche in inglese
lo dirò tradotto in italiano perché in
inglese super maccheronico
ma la paura di essere tagliati dal
momento che ogni persona tipo ha paura
di essere tagliato dalle feste sociali
sempre col cellulare in mano a
controllare i social social tipo zio che
cosa è successo qui a questa festa
controlliamo tutte le sue instagram e
facebook grazie sempre ai banchetti ho
avuto il modo di visitare paesi
abbandonare come ho già detto ma anche
luoghi terremotati che ormai sono
proprio lasciati andare ho incontrato
dei signori che mi guardavano era un
festival e mi guardano diciamo che ci
fanno così tanti ragazzi qui
ma è proprio bello vedere questi giovani
che stanno riempiendo il
i vicoli della strada ma per faceva
l'interrogatorio dicendomi ma come mai
da queste parti perché gli organizzatori
non organizzano questi eventi nelle
grandi città nel mio brand potrà far
conoscere il territorio e portare il
dialetto far tornare di modelli a letto
tra i giovani ma non in senso come posso
dire cioè che ormai un linguaggio
dimenticato i giovani quando vengono in
negozio da ma mi chiedo ma cosa vuol
dire questa parola
cosa vuol dire questa frase io la ci
rimango fatto ma come non sa cosa vuol
dire questo è casa mia non si parla più
dialetto fatto ma badate io quando ero
piccola non capivo niente perché
comunque a vasto ci sono due tipi di
dialetto cioè la star euro che è il
linguaggio più antico che parlano i
nonni e nonne e poi c'è il vastese che
il linguaggio che parliamo noi
un italiano un po dialettizza tomà nulla
di che che non ha niente a che fare
quindi sto anche cercando di portare le
13 3 al dialetto sopportando cercando di
far tornare di moda in auge come si dice
le tradizioni un po di folklore
popolare io volevo chiudere con una
citazione della guerra degli antò non
avete mai visto il film che è la frase
era ci vuole coraggio andare a vivere ad
amsterdam ma ci vuole coraggio anche a
rimanere a montesilvano che è vero
perché è una frase che ho detto faccio
girare tutto la conversazione su questa
frase però non parlando tanto anche i
problemi a ad associare dialoghi e
discorsi possa scappare adesso grazie
grazie ai mille davvero